impossible tout à remercier le peuple
malienne nous en accompagnement ou non
de sézanne et le salaire de son
affection nous dire ma décision de
quitter mes fonctions comme la fonction
à partir de ce moment
et toutes les conséquences de droit la
dissolution de l'assemblée nationale et
celle du gouvernement
après des semaines de turbulences
les manifestations diverses donc j'ai
hélas à des victimes dans lequel j'aime
un crime que je n'ai jamais souhaité
chacun dans ce pays le sait que d'une
seule
merci
nous forces patriotiques regroupés au
sein du comité national pour le salut du
peuple ctsp avons décidé de prendre nos
responsabilités devant le peuple et
devant l'histoire d'assurer la
continuité de l'état et des services
publics
ce jour 19 août 2020 toutes les
frontières aériennes et terrestres sont
fermés jusqu'à nouvel an un couvre-feu
instauré de 21h à 5h du matin jusqu à
nouvel an la continuité des services
publics sera assurée par ceux qui en ont
droit au regard des textes en vigueur
la société civile et des mouvements
sociaux politiques sont invités à nous
rejoindre pour hassan kremer conditions
d'une transition politique civile
conduisant à des élections nationales
crédibles pour l'exercice démocratique à
travers une feuille de route qui jettera
les bases d'un mali mots